what's happening you bad [__]
it's a beautiful day to be alive it's
wednesday
the 26th of may the joint is brought to
you by
zip recruiter this one goes out to all
the busy moms out there
did you know recent data shows that all
female owned businesses
one in three is owned by a mom you
didn't know that neither did i
how does a mom find time to hire
their business while juggling the family
you want to tell me
zip recruiter that's how and right now
you can try zip recruiter for free
free free free at ziprecruiter.com
joey here's the story talia goldstein is
a mother of two
and she's also the founder of a
matchmaking company
three-day rule her business is
constantly growing and she needs to hire
new matchmakers
every month that's a tough role to fill
so who does she call
zip recruiter that's who the matchmaker
for matchmakers
that powerful matching technology will
help you find
the right people with the right
experience and actively invites them to
apply
she's not the only one four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate between the
first day within
the first day now that's results so what
italian did
she got unzip recruiter so right now you
can try ziprecruiter for free
free free free at
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free what do you got to
lose you got a small business
this is the way to go four out of five
businesses pick zip recruiter they're
tremendous what else do you need to hear
try it for free just by going to
ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
the joint is also brought to you by c
b d line let me tell you something
they have some new gummies that are
[__] tremendous they're uh the
melatonin slash cbd gummies
let me tell you something i [__] eat
those and an hour later i am
out nappy new new style if you've
noticed i haven't been making the
michael jackson tee why do i
i got the melatonin from cbd lion and it
don't stop there whether it's the cream
whether it's the back balls whether it's
the cbd
flower they have now if you want to
smoke it
i mean listen the tape i don't even have
any tape left because i used it all on
my knee
that's how good that tape is cbd
lion brings you the best cbd available
this ain't no gas station
this ain't no [__] guy in a liquor
store go to cbdline.com right now read
the third party lab results
and get back to me [__] go to cbd
line
pick a cbd that works for you
press in joey or church and get 20
off delivered right to your [__]
house no more going to a liquor store
or some [__] cbd store where they
don't know dick about dick
with cbd line read the website i told
you guys
i go with sponsors per their website is
their website
is informative and it takes you to where
it needs to be
that gives me more of an opportunity to
love that [__] sponsor even more
and that's what cbd lion does but it
sucks what you're reading
go to cbdlion.com right now preston joey
your church
and get 20 off your first order let's
get this [__] party started
it's wednesday [__] we got no time to
[__] around
come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
the wu-tang clan
ain't nothing to [__] with it's
wednesday the 26th of may
a beautiful [__] day to be alive i'm
feeling great 23 days
with no weed and i still i don't know
any differences
i wish i could say to you that i'm
running swiss alps and [__] i mean i've
been working out i've been eating the
same
i'm doing the same [__] i just uh i'm
gonna keep it up to the 30-day mark
and then we'll smoke on camera i'll gag
for you guys and [__] pass out
hopefully or
then we'll give it another 30 days we're
gonna we're gonna ride this bus out
until the tolerance gets lowered i heard
through a rumor mill
that when new jersey sells weed anyway
they're only gonna sell 10
wheat that's as high as they're gonna go
that's the word on the street i don't
know how true it is
or whatever but uh it's not gonna be
[__] good so
i'm letting these jersey people know now
that you better let your tolerance go
down a little bit and
stop buying that [__] california [__]
because if they're gonna keep these
numbers low
at ten percent that's just a little bit
more than [__] susquehanna week
i think susquehanna starts at 12 so i
don't know what jersey's gonna be
[__] selling so but it's been a great
couple days listen man
going to l.a was the best thing i
[__] did because now i know where i
belong
i know that i'm home i got a home
uh you know i miss a lot of my friends i
miss a lot of the things but
not really the life that i've created
here in the last nine months
has been great and you could see it on
my face you could see it in my eyes
you know don't get old that's what sucks
getting old get sucks
so for two weeks i was waking up and i
swear to god i didn't say nothing to you
guys because i didn't want to
you know worry you guys i got enough
problems as it is i'd wake up in the
morning and i'd have to spit
because i got the sleep apnea mask and
my mouth would be dry i get up 10 times
on that idea i
drink a [__] you know you could die if
you're old over 50
you better drink a glass of [__]
water before you go to bed because you
don't want to dehydrate in the middle of
night and die
i didn't know that either i would stop
drinking water at six i'd go to bed i'd
be seeing [__] mirages because
if you the more water you drink the more
you got to pee then i'm up and down all
night [__] peeing and that sucks dick
too so
i wouldn't drink water then in the
middle of night i'm seeing [__]
mirages i'm on a desert scene a donkey
in a [__]
arab or some [__] so i said [__] i read
snow i did some reading up on it and you
got to drink a big glass of water
before you go to bed but when i still
wake up in the morning i got the sleep
apnea mask
and i would feel something on the bottom
of my teeth
and i would spit and it was [__] pure
blood so right away you know i just got
a call a few weeks ago one of my dear
friends has
cancer so now you you think well
it's the pandemic the luck of the
pandemic you know
[__] broke his [__] shoulder this
guy did this this guy did that
this guy's mother everybody had bad luck
during this [__] thing
so i'm like maybe i got [__] cancer
so i told my wife
you know because i i hid it from her for
like a week
and then i finally she saw the [__]
blood in the toilet and she's like what
is that
and i go i don't know what's going on
whenever i [__] spit
and she goes show me your mouth and i
showed it she goes look at the size of
your gums
they're [__] swollen so i took a
picture and i sent it to the dentist in
la
who had done the original work and she
goes yeah your gums don't look too good
on this side especially they were up so
i [__]
called the dentist here i made an
appointment you had to go through the
whole [__]
are you vaccinated do you need a covet i
mean
again i had to go get a [__] covet
test for the [__] dentist
it never ends i go to the dentist this
[__] tells me that
he can't go in there because he doesn't
want to redo her work or
he doesn't know how the [__] don't you
know this could only happen to me guys
i'm having the worst [__] luck with
doctors in new jersey ever
so i said you know what don't worry
about it i'm going to la anyway i called
dr sherry i said dr sherry
i'm coming in i'll only be in for a few
hours maybe two days she goes as soon as
you get off the plane call me
i have an opening i'll slip you in she
went over there she just drilled a
little bit down there was a little bit
of blood
and then she flossed and then she gave
me like an ointment to put on
and now my gums are back to normal no
problem now i wake up this morning
and i got a [__] water on my finger
how the [__] do you get a water on your
finger
i've never had a water in my life i
think it's a wart i don't [__] know
i've never had an award
and i think it's my splinter i think
it's a splinter that got infected
but don't get old because you wake up
every morning with a different [__]
helmet
i had knee surgery let me tell you
something everything hurts
except my [__] knee you understand me
i just had knee surgery
but everything else hurts except the
[__] knee my thigh hurts
my calf hurts i went to point pleasant
on [__] sunday
i pulled the [__] thing on to the
beach and sure enough
the next day my friends like sure your
legs hurt you're not supposed to go on
the beach yet
the the beach can't really [__] hold
you the sand that's the second time i
went to the beach
and [__] my legs hurt like my right
leg hurts like a [__]
so now i can't go to the beach for
another month or two because my [__]
leg i didn't know this nobody tells you
this [__]
so just do me a favor don't get old and
if you're young take care of yourself
take care of yourself drink water work
on your muscles and [__]
i got that it's just a [__] nightmare
and then you guys wonder why
i take on it and cbd and magnesium
because you got all these [__]
ailments there's an old man that you
you know i talk to rich voss every day
that's my brother i love rich boss he's
60 [__] three years old
he's another guy that lives in a world
where ailments i mean
we talk about our ailments all day i get
off the phone with him going
what the [__] did we just talk about
[__] fungi toenails and
and [__] colonoscopies and you know
so your conversation's about to change
young guys you know
like when you're 40 you're still talking
about [__] and [__] forget it once you
get to be like 50
the word [__] don't even come up no
more because you know you ain't got
nothing to give these young girls and
even if you have the chance what are you
going to do
show up with that wrinkled up [__]
ugly dick i don't want nobody to see my
dick
i'll show anybody my nut sack but my
dick you've never [__] seen my dick
every once in a while
i show it you know why because it's ugly
it's just ugly it looks like a seal now
it used to look like a dick now it looks
like a sea where you go to like san
francisco and you see the seals
they're all [__] blubbery and they
got that weird skin that's what my dick
looks like now
i don't want nobody sucking my dick i
don't want nobody looking at it i don't
want nobody taking pictures
my dick is over after 50 if you're a
woman and you're still sucking over 50
year old dick
listen i can't help you i can't help you
if you didn't get covered
that's why because you're sucking dicks
over 50 years old i don't even know what
it started here today
it's just a wednesday i'm in a great
[__] mood it's a beautiful
day to be alive and i'm happy you guys
are [__] doing great
enough is enough i've been [__] quiet
for the last [__] six months
it's time to bust the [__] out you
[__] wanted me you
[__] got me you understand me
i know there's people on there talking
[__] online i don't even give a [__] no
more
it's time for me to start talking [__]
again i'm pissed
[__] i had a great weekend though i
tell you what happened sunday night i
had the knicks
i figured let me take the hometown crowd
rule number one you never better team
let's say you live in ohio don't bet the
[__]
bulls don't bet the [__] and whoever you
have that's in ohio
whatever i don't even know ohio state
like let's say if you live in ohio they
tell you don't bet local teams
the other sunday i woke up on the next
one the playoff for the first time they
weren't even supposed to be in the
playoffs
they were getting points and i forgot to
bet them when the game started
so i went on [__] draftkings and they
[__]
let let me bet the game like in the
second quarter getting two points
so i'm all excited i [__] turn the
game on i come home from the party and
knicks are winning
i'm like i'm gonna win 47 dollars
because it's a 50 bet you win 47.
they pushed so i pushed [__] saturday
night so monday mercy's got a softball
game i go [__] it i'm at the game
my friend shows up he's like did you
look at the lines tonight what do you
like
i didn't really look at anything i i
don't i don't think the heat's going to
beat
milwaukee or whatever whoever the [__]
they played but i go i don't like either
team i don't know much about him so what
i'll do is i'll just bet the under
the [__] under loss so last night i
had to pull a [__]
a degenerate gambler move and i bet
[__] denver giving two and a half
again fifty bucks to win ninety seven ba
boom
denver one by [__] demo was given
nine and a half i'm sorry they ended up
winning
by like 20. then tuesday night i was
gonna bet the
the [__] nets again listen i love
draftkings for that reason
draftkings when you [__] sign up they
send you little emails
like last week they sent me an email
better dollar
that stefan whatever isn't gonna hit a
three-pointer are you [__] [__]
a dollar wins you 55 i'm 55 dollars
richer
you know i bet the [__] dollar you
know i love all that stupid [__]
i told you i was bored and i tell you
there's a way to gamble just to have fun
and i'm proving it to you guys
tonight i don't know who i'll take i
don't even look at the [__] games
tonight
but tonight i'll go 25 bucks that's it
25 to win
you know who cares everybody wants to
you think you're really going to make a
living off [__] yeah i love these
guys that think they're going to make a
living off gambling
i gamble just every night when you throw
on tnt they got two [__] games
every night i look at the game for two
minutes like i should have bet this game
i would have watched it
finally i said let me bet the [__]
game and i'm not having a bad week but
i'll tell you that's the one thing
that's fun about draftkings and then
they're not even sponsoring me i'm just
telling you i have a blast with them i
really do
that i don't know anything about fantasy
sports i know nothing about that
when i signed up first i signed up on
the fantasy side
i'm like what the [__] is this they have
like these dollar pools
and i'm trying to put these teams
together and my budget is too big
i don't even know what the budget is of
my [__] team so i said
i transferred my money over from fantasy
to sports betting
and i've been having a good time that's
what i wanted to tell you anyway
going to california last week was very
good move for me
because i felt ever since i got over the
[__] jet lag
and the [__] not sleeping for two
days and the whole thing it's been a lot
better i've slowed down the tea also if
you've noticed
you see i'm not posting any more
pictures after that last tea excursion
i'm done that last t-night [__] me up
i'm still drinking the tea
i'm just not blowing it up with the
[__] syringes and [__] no more
the last night i did that i had a dream
fidel castro was chasing me on a [__]
speedboat
and i could see his beard and that's
because of the weed because i'm starting
to dream in color now
it's like when you do [__] shrew it's
like when you do alpha brain
you start dreaming in black and white
now that i removed the reefer
i'm starting to dream in color and
that's [__] scary because i never had
dreams i don't remember even [__]
dreaming
i pass out so hard at night on those
[__] edibles you know i don't even
have dreams i wake up in the morning and
my eyes are [__] red
but i've been having dreams that's one
thing about not smoking reefer
that i've been having very vic
visual colored dreams
so the last week or so this has been
going on like for the last 10 days i had
a dream about my mother
had a dream fidel was chasing me
i had a dream i was doing comedy
somewhere and i was bombing and i was
cursing myself for getting on stage you
know
i just have these weird [__] dreams
so if you want me to know what's going
on that's the only difference
from the smoking weed is that my [__]
eyes uh that
i'm having [__] colored dreams that's
the only difference i'm getting that's
what i hear
sophie up yeah that's it i'm just
getting weird dreams and uh
i'm seeing them in color but as
wednesdays
we have a guest today i've known this
guy for a long [__] time
i've seen him go from being an open
miker
to a real comic and i have nothing
but respect for this young man um
before the pandemic he had a lot of
things going on
like a lot of us and the pandemic took a
lot of those things from him
he was going to shoot a special he had a
couple things going on so
uh i checked in with him you know we
check in with each other once a month
and a couple weeks ago i was talking to
him and i figured
let me uh put him on the show he had a
[__] uh
[__] up time during the pandemic i
mean he didn't lose anybody or nothing
like that it was great but
he had a lot of things to lose the
things i lost
i didn't even sweat i knew that people
were going through rougher times so i
never made a big deal about them
i never even mentioned them until today
on the interview and i lost so
it doesn't matter we have our health we
have our families
we have our jobs and sometimes that's
the most important thing
that's what i've gotten from this
[__] uh last 15 months
that's the most important thing so when
you have all those things
and now my mind like i said i needed a
couple months to pull the [__] layers
off the artichoke
the artichoke is starting to show it's
like my dick i'm uncircumcised
if you look at it it's got the [__]
skin on the top i gotta pull the skin
back so you can see the helmet the pink
meat
it's the same thing with me the pink
meat is starting to come out [__]
so get ready you know what i'm saying
i've been getting the itch too i'm not
saying nothing i think i'm gonna start
doing some guest spots here
next month i got a busy this month
baseballs tournaments
softball tournaments you know i got a
lot of [__] going on
but i've been writing lately uh thank
god
mikey gave me the gift of the guitar
it's opened up my mind a lot uh in
different ways
i'm doing things for the guitar i still
suck but at least i'm getting sounds out
of it
you know what i'm saying which is
something that i never got before i'm
getting sounds out of it
i have an idea what i'm doing no i'm not
ready to play for you [__]
suckers come on jimmy but uh
thank you for the people who have
encouraged me there have been a lot of
people who have sent me free material on
the guitar
and it just shows me that uh what comes
around goes around man i helped you at
one time and now you guys want to help
me back
so thank you very much i hope you enjoy
this interview with mr josh potter
josh p hey hey there he is
looking good what's happening you bad
[__]
dude not much man just getting back in
the groove baby
things are opening up you getting on
stage
i'm trying i'm trying my best oh [__] my
bad
first of all i gotta give you props get
it sturdy for you here
you [__] sir you're [__] you're
sticking it out in la
and i got to give you props for that
brother yeah man i got i mean i
i was presented with the choice of
moving and then um
it was it was removed so i i found
myself with the uh like hey i guess i
could go wherever i want really but then
i just
i just figure like [__] it man i'm gonna
stay
and uh and stick it out and see what
happens i just got here it kind of feels
like still so
and you know now maybe uh la comes down
to
to my level a little bit you know what
i'm saying we level up a little together
you know i'm coming enough to be coming
down yeah yeah i see the lineups and i
see a lot of people are missing and uh
i'm happy for a lot of the young guys
that stayed you know it looked dark for
a while
but uh nobody knew where comedy was
going
i mean i can't imagine like last june i
didn't know where the [__] this was
going
i had no intention of going on stage i
had no
nothing i mean and i thought about other
comics i kept in touch with his money
you know i pushed that podcast till
august
until we left yeah i mean i pushed it
all the way to the end
scared did it with a mask on you know i
was scared to [__] in fact
guess you know it was just too rough and
uh it broke my heart when i left a
little bit i felt like a quitter
you know but i knew i wasn't quitting i
was
just this was the evolution of my life
you know
i got to l.a like you you know ready to
[__] stab a [__]
on the bottom level you know not getting
spots nobody talks to you
you know people make fun of your little
[__] remarks
and you work yourself up and i saw you
doing great before i left
i mean you were really out there every
night i know the podcast was getting
numbers
people were listening to you so you know
yeah it was so good
i mean the beginning of this whole thing
when it happened i was like of course
like it felt um like a personal
attack you know everyone was going
through it though so you couldn't i know
you can't have that mentality you lost a
lot more than what i lost
i know that you had a lot of things
in the works you had like a special you
had a couple great [__] things
happening
and i remember telling lee to send you
my love he i know he went on his podcast
and i go
send him my love i know that his job was
because you had all these things
it was going to be your bust out [__]
year you know what i'm saying
i lost like the sopranos i lost opening
up for joe at the garden
like i was going yeah that's the square
garden 10 minutes 15 minutes at the
boston garden
the home of the [__] boston celtics
you know i lost a lot but
i there was people who lost their lives
unfortunately
[__] about a comedy gig you know what
i'm saying like that's in june
i was kind of bummed and i was mad at
the pandemic
but i'm like there's [__] freezers
filled with bodies whether the pandemic
killed them whoever killed them
trump's cousin i don't [__] know but
they were people were dying
yeah so i wasn't worried this whole
[__] stupid comedy gig
you know when people started opening up
clubs i got very angry
because it was highly contagious and i
know you need to laugh and need to get
out
but not at the expense of somebody
getting sick every time there was a
comedy show
and there was 300 people in that room
somebody died
yeah somewhere from the result of that
[__] i remember
i i had the same train of thought like
eventually it came down to the
effect where i was like you know sitting
here getting pissed off
about you know losing gigs and all that
[__] because like you said i mean
my first headline like headlining the
clubs i always like you know you scratch
and claw just to get a guest set at
before and now you're headlining them
and you're you know you're going on this
run
and then it all got wiped away and i i
was pissed off and like upset
but then like you said you know you see
the bodies stacking up you see people
who like you started really like toward
the fall
knowing people who got sick from it and
my you know my mom got it my sister
everybody got it
and it started like you know you're like
this is bigger obviously than like you
said like a comedy gig or whatever you
know what i mean people are losing like
their
lives and their family members and all
that [__] so
yeah it's rough and it even made me take
like a more important
like personal inventory than just comedy
too you know because
i sat here without comedy for the first
time in 12 years or whatever
and i was like man i'm realizing i don't
really have much else
you know like there's not much else
around me neither
so i mean but you got you know your
daughter you got your wife and
everything like that i
i realized you know i've been running
around these past 12 years chasing a
certain dragon
and i wasn't really putting uh the
things in the place to have a life
outside of that kind of thing and
i need to like concentrate on that a
little bit more you know i'm [__] 35
now you know so
i did the personal inventory also it was
kind of weird that you had no choice at
one point
you're in a room you're alone it's june
when the pandemic first started i got to
be honest
i was happy they were cancelling gigs
i'm like at least cancel till june
we'll be back in july or whatever you
know i could do vegas and this
and then i just uh i lost
like i was like there's so many bad
things happening
you know so many like i see so many
homeless and this and then
when i got this thrown at me about
moving you know
this was big on me this [__] war on
me like
i didn't care about comedy all i wanted
was my daughter and wife to be happy
and safe and in [__] school
and in [__] school that was my thing
you know so
this move for me like austin didn't
really
wasn't uh a thought it didn't even come
into my mind
because i knew i was coming home i
wanted to come home i had been done when
i came back here to shoot in 2019
i just thought that i was missing too
much and that i wanted my daughter to
experience what i had
in jersey and i'm happy i'm just [__]
generally even more like
i don't know if you know this has been
22 days since i smoked weed how the [__]
no way 22 [__] days no reefer
you know i think it was the johnson
johnson vaccine they put some in those
[__]
that doesn't let me smoke anymore i
don't know what the [__] happened but
that's 22 more days than me my friend
i'll tell you oh no and i'm not craving
it i'm not in a bad mood
i'm not yelling at anybody i'm not cur i
don't have road rage i didn't shoot a
five-year-old in the stomach and i like
you know
i have none of these [__] things
going on which is rare
because when i first had to go off weed
in prison i was like a [__] monster
the first week i couldn't sleep
i was yelling at everybody i was
throwing pots and pans
but then after the selling you like uh
no reefer but
i just wanted to i think i needed just
to restart
like you know like what's that thing you
do with your computer yeah reboot
reboot i just needed a reboot you know i
had to slow down with the [__] drugs
i'm 58 years old i'm eating 10 000
milligrams a day
i'm walking around my skin feels like
alligator skin now i got moisture in my
skin
my feet don't stink anymore i had this
thing coming out of my feet between the
fungi toenail
and the cheese it was murder i would go
to jiu jitsu and people be looking
around what's that [__] stink
i started putting tea tree all on my
toenails now they're beautiful i look
like [__] i got like elba's feet
you know what i'm saying the fungi
toenail is done that little stink in my
[__] sock i had like a little wink
in my sock and cheese and it smelled
like subway sandwiches and my [__]
sneakers so
i made changes everywhere what have you
done now what have you got
what have you put together now well i've
been uh i mean i've
now it's like things are opening again
so i've kind of been you know
now it's like let's get a let's get our
nut together let's get a nice living
situation
get out of this apartment you know i
have a roommate i'm [__] 35 i got a
[__] roommate like i wanna you know
that's terrible i gotta get the [__] out
so that's my goal i mean i just wanna
have a nice setup
like an adult would for once you know
and uh
afford that and like you know gather
some things you know i don't know like
uh
it's not like i know those things aren't
going to make me happy but it's like you
know you get a couch you get a couple
things going then you got a girlfriend
and then you got a [__]
you know a girl that you know comes over
once in a while you have dinner and
you know stuff like that normal [__]
uh as opposed to like you know [__]
bringing home some bar haggad for it you
know what i'm saying like it's just
the differences in the lifestyle and
that kind of way come with i feel like
just having a living space
uh you know for myself and i can grow
from there you know
so now we got the new studio going up
and i'm gonna move out that way
and then i hopefully i can just you know
walk to that ride my bike or whatever
because i'm not driving out here at all
so
you know that's the goal man and then
hopefully you know down the road i'd
love you know
i'd love to start a family it's never
been something i even thought of until
the pandemic i always thought like
yeah maybe down the road or whatever but
i realized during the pandemic the road
is here i mean this is it dude i'm
[__] mid 30s like now all of a sudden
it went it like crept i i felt like i
was 33
just starting to headline on the road
and then all of a sudden now i'm 35
and it's like it didn't it hasn't really
started yet and all of a sudden i'm 35
it's like whoa
it's a bit of a shock in terms of i
don't know why the two years but it's
all of a sudden i'm kind of like holy
[__] dude you're [__]
getting up there you know josh potter
you're 35 years old
at 35 years old i wasn't thinking
about anything except comedy you know i
was so
every i was a loser in every other
aspect
i couldn't get your job you know i
[__] hated jobs
you know that's one thing about the
pandemic like in june that i was i was
cursing my comedian success
because i was like you got to be really
careful what you wish for
because it just might happen i wished
for not having a day job
now i'm sitting here on my hands all
[__] day during the pandemic
maybe i should go to rouse and stock
supermarket shows or whatever you know i
i felt like i wanted to do something
different
during the pandemic like i just like
how the [__] did i get to this point
that i don't have a job now
yeah that makes sense and you got to be
careful what you wish for
so i didn't think at 35
i was grinding it out i was snorting
coke i was bringing home bar eggs
i was contacting diseases you know
you're fingering people on
triple runs you know there's no
stability you don't give a [__] about
living on couches and i gotta tell you
no yeah that's the same here and then
the pandemic woke me up from that it was
weird it was like hey man like
i would have kept i would still be on
this path you know what i mean but it
was like it was this
pause and all of this that made me go
like whoa dude like this is what
you've been doing this for you know 12
years and i'm gonna still keep
doing it by the way i'm gonna keep going
hard but it made me go
like hey i should pay attention a little
bit to
becoming a man too you know
well that didn't happen for me i was 44.
nine years ahead of me like when i was
i had nothing i had nothing i was a
guy that had a couple movies under his
belt
and i couldn't cut it together i was
headlining but i wasn't a headliner
you know not even close you know and uh
i knew i had to get the drugs out of my
life that was the first step
and i got the drugs out of my life and
then my girlfriend became more important
to me
and then my girlfriend ended up becoming
my wife
i still resisted it i still resisted
that normal life
then my wife got pregnant i was ready to
quit stand up in 2009.
oh [__] a lot of people don't know that
that i was out i was like i'm
open for joe you know i wasn't doing
spots at the store yet i go
open for joe i'll do spots at the haha
and
when my friends call me and spoon me
movies you know i have friends that call
you and say you want three days on a
movie
i'll do it and then the podcast world
came along and that
picked up stand up and that's how i got
to this place but i was out
i was checked out i had already known
that
i had been running from not having a
family
for 20 years like i had been i had once
i got divorced
it affected my inside so much that i
didn't want to deal with that pain ever
again
and my wife just stayed on me you know
she stayed on me and then i started
turning over the business to her
you know i started asking her for advice
should i take this gig
is this gig worth it and she started
telling me no we became a team
and now everything has changed i i wish
this would have happened
10 years earlier when i was 35 but i was
too hard-headed and i was too stupid so
i applaud you
for thinking in that direction that's
the best applause there is
oh yeah no don't worry about nothing
that was my garlic pill sorry about
that people i promised i wouldn't fart
on this podcast but from time to time
[__] happens what i'm saying what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do and
it smells tremendous
these are the times when you need a mask
you know what i'm saying like yeah right
now
if 10 people were in this room and smelt
this fart they put that mask
on so [__] fast
but hey it happens from time to time you
got to drop a bomb
here and there just to let people know
i'm back you know
i went you know i was in la last week i
know i heard you snuck out here for a
little bit you said
tennis crazy 10 hours wow really i was
supposed to be there for three days
wow i took a look at ventura
they closed the chinese restaurant they
closed so many [__] things on mentor
oh yeah hollywood's a mess it broke my
heart
i looked that lanka lancashire yeah
and my heart was broken so i basically
my
bret from some conscious jiu jitsu
picked me up
he took me right to [__] ice cream
cake
i got my weed you know i ordered my
stuff
from there i had to go to the dentist
because my gums got all [__] up i put
caps on before i left
oh my gums gotten [__] infected i was
waking up every morning spitting blood
right away for people who don't know me
i spit blood i got cancer
i'm calling [__] you know i'm at
brick hospital tell them i got cancer
that i'm [__] to see if blood comes
out of my ass because another one of my
friends got diagnosed with
uh cancer so now for two weeks i was
spitting
blood i would come on the pie i wouldn't
say nothing and then one day i told my
wife i don't know what this is it's com
the blood is conglomerating behind these
teeth
oh [__] she looked at it and she goes
your gums are [__]
horrible take a picture and show the
dentist so i showed the dentist
then she told me to go to a dentist here
that dentist told me
i don't want to redo the work she did
like if you need it so i said you know
what i gotta go to la anyway i'll just
see it
so i stopped by her she made a couple
[__] things she
gave me a prescription for a cream and
then i had i checked into the hotel the
holiday inn on noho across from denny's
oh yeah i saw a [__] i'm sitting
there and i see a tent with a crib next
to it
i probably walked by you by the way when
you're over there really
yeah yeah i go i walk over there do
bikes every now and then
and i said you know what i'm not [__]
staying here tonight
i go you know i was walking down uh
sunset
up in the east part like in silver lake
area in the night
and i wa i'm walking up alone you know
and there's a baby stroller
at the corner and i'm just like i don't
want to even
look inside there because it's so
[__] gnarly out here you know what i
mean i don't even want to know what's in
the baby stroller
just in case you know what i'm saying so
i just walked by and i pretend i didn't
see nothing you know
and i can get away with that kind of
thing you know no i won't look either
like i was like i don't know i was just
sitting outside waiting for dean delray
we were going to go with some tacos and
i'm like is that a homeless tent
with a crib next to it and
under a tree they had it perfectly it
broke my heart
yeah no it's not across the street to
see if there was a lady there i would
have thrown over 20
or got a milk or something but there was
nobody in there so
they just live in there and then they
leave in the day i don't know what the
[__] it was
it wasn't listen it wasn't the homeless
it wasn't the businesses
what i realized was my time was done in
l.a
i'd done a short time sometimes you do
your [__] duty
you're done i knew i wasn't gonna go to
the store i said my goodbyes to the
store already i went to the building i
rubbed my name on the wall i [__]
sat on the stairs with my daughter i
told her a few stories i did all this in
july
so i made my piece with the store i had
made my piece with los
angeles i went out there just to take
care of some stuff look today just my
wife
just went now to pick up the
prescription that the doctor
see the doctor here wouldn't give me the
medication i needed
and he didn't want to lift my blood
pressure medication
and that was the other thing for the
last [__]
60 day no [__] i got surgery five months
ago
for the last six months i take my blood
pressure twice a day
is it going down perfect nice
it was it was perfect 120 over 80.
sometimes i wake up in the morning and
it's 1 30 over 80
but i'm still in the neighborhood do you
know what my blood pressure was
in la at three o'clock when i walked
into the doctor's office
oh my god what was it it was 180
over a hundred jesus
and he was like joey what's going on i
go give me 10 minutes
because it was a new chick that took my
blood pressure
then he took it and it was still 160
over a hundred
oh what's going on with you because we
talk all the time me and my heart doctor
i got one here in jersey but he's up
tight
so i just talked to my [__] he's a
jewish dude i love this [__] we
talk about
porn and you know he's just a dirty [__]
i love him he's great
he's 66 and uh
i went to just that's how much how
uncomfortable i was in la
when i got back to the hotel room i'm
like i'm not even laying on that bed
i'm getting the [__] out of here that's
great and right on the same day
right back just on the side go my back's
gonna be dead
tomorrow if i'm sitting for 12 hours but
i don't want to [__] i'm not spending
the night here
i didn't know what to do in l.a all day
friday
what was i going to do sit in my room
i'm not smoking yeah i didn't know where
you were i didn't know if you were in
town i didn't know if you were opening
for tom on the road
no no sure i mean it's um it's
it was empty on ventura it was empty on
lancashire
lancashire i saw some weird stuff they
did clean up a lot i didn't see
a lot of homeless in north hollywood not
hot i did notice in the last like
months north hollywood's gotten a little
bit better i mean it was like i remember
it was like thunder dome down there for
a little while
there was that that sign i get out of
the subway station there on north
hollywood
and i walk to the you know the corner
there of lankershim and
i forget the burbank boulevard and
there's that uh big
welcome to north hollywood like concrete
triangle pyramid thing and some people i
assume homeless people picked it up and
like moved it into the street
because they and so they could sleep on
that part of the the land
like they took this concrete structure i
don't know how many people it took to
lift them but it was like so [__] up
that they moved it
so far away from where it was it just
stayed there i was like who's going to
move that back the cops aren't going to
[__] move it back
no one's touching it so it just stayed
like in this middle of the road kind of
area
train station what pushed me over the
top
that train station was the station that
i left because my office was right there
yeah she taped the podcast right there
if you get off the train
and walk to the corner and cross the
street and keep going and i drink that's
right when i came to do your show i did
that exact thing you hit the office you
have no choice but
at the office so one afternoon i think
it was we did joe mchale i got it there
like at four
and i took the long way around you know
just to stop on lancashire i was gonna
go to a weed store something you know
yeah and i went that way and i made a
right on that and then there's a light
next to the golf store
and people cross the street in between
the train they put a coffee shop
there and [__] yep and i'm sitting there
minding my own business
you know i'm at the light and i'm just
looking around
listening to ozzie's boneyard or
whatever the [__] i got on serious
and i just look over to the left and i
swear to god i see a lady
waiting for the bus because there's a
bus station there too the train station
and then they don't then there's cabs
all the way to the corner
you know you get dropped off there and a
cop sees you it's a 200
ticket you can't even get drunk elite
told me that you found that out the hard
way yeah i got a 200 ticket dropping my
wife off over there one day
you can't even stop there so i'm i'm
looking at this lady at this train
for some reason i just looked over at
this lady and i saw a [__] four by
four
hit her right on the head and she fell
on the lancashi
and then i go what the [__] is that
and i see the guys start hitting people
one one at a time
four in the afternoon they're going down
now you know exactly where i am at that
light yeah
he's he's he's probably hit by now three
people
oh my god a lady and he hit like two
guys but he hit a chubby guy
and the chubby guy got up now i'm
thinking it's a crazy homeless guy right
like right away you see a stick flying
you want to assume nationalities and
racisms and all this [__] right
so like i'm sitting there going this has
to be some crazy [__]
you know whatever and next thing you
know
the fat guy throws a punch and he hits
the guy
and i could see that you know once
people started getting hit they started
spreading
people like what the [__] so now the
clouds parted and i can see the true
color of the sky
i see the guy with the axe handle not
the axe handle but a four by four
and he gets punched in the face he kind
of like loses consciousness he looks at
the chubby guy
the chubby guy picks up his suitcase and
just dodges across the street
now i see the guy with the 4x4 chasing
him he's got no t-shirt on he's got a
warrior's vest on
and he's a white black guy all my racist
whatever went out the window right like
i'm like up
it was the mexican dude you know like i
thought it was like a [__] illegal or
something
no it wasn't those meth tweakers man
those those methods
yeah those next tweakers they'll [__]
stab you on silver lake and [__] so i'm
watching this guy
go across the street like he runs right
in front of me
and he's chasing the chubby guy and the
chubby guy is scared because he hit him
with everything he got
and [__] rambo didn't even move he
just like
was a little rattled and the next thing
you know i go you know what
i'm making a [__] u-turn i'm gonna
hit this
because i can catch him by the office
and he's never witnesses by the office
there's never
anybody by that office like there's
never anybody on that street you could
shoot a [__]
in front of that funeral parlor and no
nobody'll see you
so i made a [__] u-turn and i made
the street name is hartsuke isn't it
i think so that was where my office was
i made the left
and when i made the left i
waited for him at that corner to see
where he was gonna go and i could pick
him off with
the [__] saw me he ran up and he
saw me with the car
and he turned around he ran back towards
the train and he hooked the [__] left
back to lancashire
you knew you were going to run him over
he knew i was up to something because i
was like i looked at him like
okay just run into the street i'm gonna
hit you with this car i didn't know i
was gonna hit him
and keep going or i was gonna hit him
and dial 9-1-1 and say it was an
accident and then put the two-by-four on
his hand and
there'd be three this guy was running
around like a looney tune
anyway so he just ran in the street in
front of the car that's awesome so when
i passed him i actually looked up the
corner
and that was really sad the chubby guy
was on the floor and there was a puddle
of blood laying to his head oh my god
that's the kind of [__] dude that i
don't know that's like a way to [__]
go you know just some guy at the train
station
and i'm like i went home and told my
wife i think it's time to abandon ship
and then she went to the post office
which is right down the block from there
because if you cross that street there's
a there's a bus station and then there's
like a coffee shop they put a coffee
shop in there
across the coffee shop is the post
office and along that line
there used to be homeless people they
cleaned them up and the day she went
she couldn't get in there because one of
the homeless guys stabbed the other
homeless guy
was bleeding right in the [__] street
right there by the post office she's
like whoever's getting t-shirts on get
them this week because
i went to make a [__] delivery and
some guy got stabbed the cop wouldn't
let her go back there
so i'm like the guy who sells socks on
the train just got stabbed
you know and like you [__] you know
you're from buffalo
you know you've seen crime in buffalo
sometimes they tailgate and the buffalo
bill guy will hit another guy in the
head with a helmet you know
that's buffalo that's buffalo you know
new york city's new york city you're
going to get mugged up at the
high you accept that you know what i'm
saying you accept that
you go down to camden new jersey you're
going to get mugged
you know you go to philadelphia now you
might get hit in the head you know what
i'm saying but that's the east coast
we've always had that for that i didn't
i didn't grow
up watching california going to
california to see that type of stuff i
never saw that type of stuff in god
right and that's why i kind of feel like
i i should stay
you know like i it's part of the reason
why i'm like oh i'm feeling it's not
that i'm feeling more comfortable with
everything but it is more like
everyone who i felt uncomfortable around
seems to be out of their element now
whereas i'm just kind of like yeah it's
like you know the crime whatever you
know it's homeless people it's crime
like
i have that you know people used to come
from new york city to buffalo and be
really sketched out so
that i always found funny because i
always thought buffalo's like a small
town you know what i mean i never
thought of it as like scary in any way i
always felt
safe everywhere i went but i'd have
friends come visit and they'd be like
this is gnarly dude like
you live over here buffalo is no
joke i told you i used to do rob
liederman's room way
in 98 and i used to take the bus from
port authority up there so i was at that
bus station a couple times
yeah one day i'm in buffalo i'm minding
my own [__] business
there was a mcdonald's close to there or
something and i walked over to
mcdonald's because my bus was delayed or
some [__]
and i bought one of those breakfast
sandwiches with the potato and the
[__] soda and the apple pie
and i just finished eating it i don't
want a litter in buffalo you know what
i'm saying
when i was a kid i was a litterer and
then you got to make peace with mother
nature mother nature's a [__]
you know [__] you throw a piece
you throw a can out the window next
thing you know you're in florida in a
hurricane so
you got to be careful with mother nature
she'll drop some karma on you so
i was walking the bag to the garbage
something i would never do
you know what i'm saying right mcdonald
bag throwing the [__] floor but i was
a comic i was trying to
you know be the right person so i go let
me go over and throw this away
dog i'm not 10 steps from the garbage
can and some buffalo brother
because buffalo brothers are cool as
[__] he came running up to me huffing
and puffing he's like yo
chubby dude yo what he goes chubby dude
you want to buy a gold chain i got that
ain't gold because this is gold in a
[__] i just took it off the
dude's neck
and i went in my pocket i had a 20 that
i paid for the breakfast the breakfast
is four dollars
so i had like 15 and change like
all i got is 15 and change it's like
good to go
i just had that gold chain until about
10 years ago i swear to god
no [__] that gold chain was solid i
don't know what i lost in the hotel
because when he rip
when he ripped it off the person's neck
the lock stayed on their neck so i had
to
use a like a pin and the pin finally
[__] popped i was too lazy to go to
the jewelry store
still got the guy's hair that [__]
chain had dna on it blood
that black dude told me yo chubby dude
you want to buy a train
[__] chain i don't give a [__] i used
to live like two blocks from that train
station
that's what my friends were talking
about when they came to visit they were
like this is this is weird it's a
sketchy bus station dog
yeah i went there one night and i saw
some sketchy [__] like i always
got out of there in the daytime but one
time like i had like uh
i think i was going that's right i used
to go to buffalo
to sneak into canada so i had a my
friend's
father was a gambling dude and he was a
high roller
up in canada so they had a back road
he didn't even have to go to the border
so he would take me to the back
road because i'll buy like ottawa and
[__] yes
not even ottawa i would get off that
would be close to
i'd be in london canada okay yeah yeah
i would take the bus to toronto from
there but the funny thing was when i
came back
he wouldn't pick me up i take the bus
back so when i get to the buffalo
when they check my paperwork they put me
in the computer and they see all those
felonies
and they go how the [__] did you get in
here when did you get in here and i was
like i was here thursday you were here
you're the one that let me in
he's like i would never let you in here
look at this crime record you have i'm
like i'm telling you i got in here by
you
it was oh
we didn't work on thursday i go yes you
did i would do that
constantly and then after 9 11 they got
hip to me and they're like listen you
ever come back in here again
we'll [__] throw you under the jail
yeah i'm not allowed in
canada myself and growing up in buffalo
it was like such a
shitty thing because you're 10 minutes
from the i was going to canada all the
[__] time
and you know you don't even know that
when you're like
you get a dwi in texas you don't know
that you're banned from canada for like
a decade or whatever
but you find out real quickly in buffalo
that you're banned
and uh i got stuck one time
because i didn't realize that it was
like a 10 year [__] band and they
were like you know they flagged me and
they did all that [__]
and uh i started asking around because i
started getting just for laughs like
auditions and stuff and i was like what
if i get this how am i going to get up
there you know
and a bunch of comics who had dui they
showed me like where people would run
like almost like mexicans run across the
border to come into america
it's like that to go into canada they
show you the routes and you're like you
just you
they'll be speaking french on the other
side of the woods basically so
you'll know you're there so i was like
okay you learn a little
yeah a bunch of comics uh that were new
york comics used to like
make that jog like when they would get
the festival if they couldn't get into
the country they would be like i can't
afford a lawyer or whatever to pay to
like fix this for me
so they there was like little routes
that a couple guys would tell me about
running across the border
to go to canada to go to just for laughs
of all things
josh potter it's been really good to see
you man
you're good to see you too thank you so
much for having me how long have
we known each other like i i don't even
know how many times i went to buffalo
and you hooked me up
and [__] we get the [__]
b you know the mayor of buffalo
contacted me
i remember five years ago when i was at
buffalo one of the last times i was at
the casino
oh okay the casino called me and they're
like you have a call downstairs from
such and such and i called them with
some lady and she's like the man would
like to speak to you
no way yeah and they're like thank you
for [__] talking about buffalo like
you do
these [__] idiots that put ranch on
their wings i want to shoot them all
but you've restored that [__] dog
oh no she was like [__] idiots
[__] ranch dressing
[__] buffalo was built on blue cheese
and you live by those standards thank
god
you know i was like i'm old school
you know i i went to buffalo the first
time in 84
and that was i fell in love with that
city
i've never met a person from buffalo i
didn't like
i loved people there i missed it when i
was in boulder i had three or four
friends that were from buffalo
and i couldn't believe how [__] crazy
and real they were and then when i got
locked up i was locked up with a couple
brothers that were from boulder
and i couldn't believe how real
they were like people from buffalo they
you know they're not gonna have no
skinny jean [__] in buffalo not
the buffalo i remember
i still remember going to buffalo to see
rick james
yeah and i can't tell you what that was
like you saw him in buffalo too so
that's great i mean it must have been a
small show
with sperm breath you know because there
was a ton of white chicks ready to suck
rick james's dick i never saw anything
like that
most people sign up like after my shows
they get online to take a picture
not rick james they got online to suck
his dick that's it
if you're a white chick with blonde hair
you're sucking uncle rick's dick
there's no me too there's no movies
there's no script
you know rick just would slip you a
valium and then give you a breath mint
afterwards so kalaminka dirty [__]
you paid 20 for the show i swear to god
i went up there people were giving me
pills in the audience
it was it was 1984. i will never ever
forget that and i fell in love with rick
james in 78
with you and i i go back with rick james
to the [__] first down i was just
listening to rick james the other night
street street
what's that how many did street songs
it is [__] brutal he did not [__]
around uncle rick i used to see him at
all
buffalo's best son he used to used to
come to the store how many clubbers
around buffalo too he'd show up to
different places different venues and
everything all
right really perform yeah he would just
like
bars and do sets it was crazy like just
do
sing and [__] like that and like people
tell stories about it all the time you
go to all the bars they talk about oh
rick james has been in here you know
they got his
picture on the wall and [__] they got
autographs and [__] he's graves in
buffalo have you been to his grave
never never got a buffalo i'm gonna go
to his grave
i met him at the comedy story i met him
at the comedy store and i went up to him
right
chewie introduced me to him the doorman
coming up to chewie i got to meet rick
james and i don't want to meet nobody if
you know anything about me i don't need
nobody
but there was something by rick james i
had to tell him of course
so i met him i shook his hand i'm a big
fan from you and i
i told him all the albums i had i told
him i saw him in 84
in buffalo and i go let me tell you
something when i first started comedy
one of my best jokes
was about you because when i started
coming in 91 maybe two years later it
was only tied to chick up
and burned them with a crack pipe and
[__] yeah
and i'm like rick i gotta be honest with
you the first good joke i wrote
was about you i thought i don't remember
the joke and i'm not going to give it
any justice it was like if
if i picked a black superhero it would
be like rick james because he's
got a crack pipe that's never been done
before you know it was something stupid
maybe a blowtorch i don't [__] know
but he was very nice
and then shortly after that he died
maybe a year after that he died i never
saw him at the store again but it was uh
i think that was one of my biggest
nights at the store i mean he was great
and he looked up at mooney afterwards
i remember that morning we were talking
mooney and him were talking and eddie
griffin he was good he was good to
everybody
so every time paul mooney would come to
town to buffalo he would have he would
regale you with stories with rick james
too like he would be his favorite
subject so you get to hear from
him kind of like about a guy who came
out of buffalo so it was fun
every time he came to town rest in peace
of course
yeah both of them yeah both of them josh
potter what are your plans buddy
where can these people see you because
you're a great man
i'm sorry about what happened to you
last year because i knew you had a lot
of big things that were about to [__]
blow up in your favor
but you know what bro you didn't lose
nothing no you're wiser
and like you said strong the perspective
i
uh you know i could have been way worse
and i didn't lose a
loved one or myself my own life or my
health in any way i didn't even get sick
i didn't even get sick when i got the
[__] second dose of that [__] i
didn't get any i didn't
you're from buffalo dog that that that
fire don't do dick to you you got that
[__]
yeah you got that blue cheese in you
that's i i think if you eat blue cheese
you don't get covered i really do
because
all my blue cheese friends didn't get
covered none of my buffalo friends got
covered i checked with the one guy he's
fine
he's still selling cars you got any
dates on the books anything
i do uh i'm uh well i'm doing my podcast
comes out every tuesday
just search the josh potter show on uh
youtube subscribe or whatever
uh but i got june 9th i'm gonna be in
tampa florida
at the tampa improv and then the day
after june 10th orlando improv so
those are the two big ones so i hope i
see people out at those
you coming up to jersey anytime soon or
anything i could say hello
i'll give you a hug i'd like to get up
to the stress factory you know people
keep asking like are you coming here you
come in here and i'm telling them like
i'm coming anywhere
people booked me i told my guy who's
booking my dates i said grind me into
[__]
dust like let's go so um
hopefully i i get to go everywhere and
hopefully i'll be up to jersey soon but
these are the only two
dates i have so far and i'm supposed to
hear back i think
in a couple of days here about some the
rest of the summer in the fall so
hopefully i'll have more coming soon
here
you start the fourth wall you're still
doing spots around town
stuff working out oh yeah i go to the
fourth wall
almost every other day noon one o'clock
you know and then
i'm getting some sets here and there now
and other shows and
uh the improv uh and you know the
store's opening back up i'm hoping to
work my way into there too soon so um
it's a new era or whatever there so i'm
hoping to
hop aboard that train and see if i can
get get some sets out that way too you
know
if i could help you with emily let me
know if i could thank you thank you
for you because i know you're a hard
worker
i know you've been at it for a while i
still remember you and me and buffalo
eating tacos or something
all the donuts oh yeah the donuts
the first time you came you brought the
banana bread [__]
oh [__] 2011. got that mailed over it
was right after yoshi like almost killed
himself or whatever
and uh i remember ari telling me to like
relax on it but i didn't listen
and i remember i think that's where we
bonded though because i ate so much of
it and i wasn't a piece of [__]
afterwards
but the one morning you took me for
doughnuts oh yeah the doughnut famous
donut place up there that's
uh we went to uh uh paula's polished
ballers and they had like a cream
doughnut and the [__] game was
sensational
i [__] hate donuts but i love that
[__] you know i love yum yum donuts
i'm not a dunkin donut man these [__]
suck these donuts in new jersey
paul's a [__] delish paul is a dog
you took me for donuts
i was like that was i told lee i go lee
i could ate 15 of them but
i didn't want to be a [__] slob in
front of josh pilot
told tom segura i ate [__] donuts
i love you buddy i appreciate you coming
on uh
good luck to you if you need something
with the comedy store let me know if i
can help you with emily at all
put in a word for you to get you a
showcase or at least a tape and uh
i'm sorry you had these gigs taken away
from you but let me tell you something
you're a great
young comic so and you're a great guy so
it's gonna all come back to you brother
tenfold you got my word thank you so
much i love you for everything i
it means the world to me to get to come
on your show and talk to you
you know i love you and uh i miss you
out here but you know i'm happy that
things are going so well for you out
there man you look good i'm glad you're
starting to feel good
you're being around people that you love
so that's tremendous and uh
congratulations on all that well i love
you and let's stay in touch
okay don't forget don't be a stranger
[__] give my best to buffalo
blue cheese with wings and go [__] your
mother
of course i love you buddy thank you
stay back thank you brother
all right you [__] bloodsuckers i
hope you enjoyed that [__] little
tatte with josh potter he's a good kid
follow him on twitter don't forget his
podcast drops every tuesday
and he's just like me that's me [__]
20 years ago trying to put the pieces
together
support support make somebody's day
that's what this whole [__] movement
has been about is making somebody's
[__] day
whether it's been the patreon or the
podcast i never stopped
because i know you guys you know what
i'm saying even if i come on in i'm
confused
i still i'm thinking of you guys at all
times so thank you very much for
watching the show today
thank you for watching on monday thank
you for always having my back
uh patreon the whole thing we're still
doing our thing and uh i love you
[__]
when i get dates when i'm ready to
[__] headline
i will let patreon people know first and
then so on and so forth
but i could feel the itch coming so i'm
happy about that and it's all because of
you guys
thank you very much and i'll see you
next week now
for a word from our sponsors and happy
[__] memorial day
all right i want to thank my man josh
potter for coming on the podcast today
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for supporting our podcast
listening
busting my balls giving me love whatever
the [__] you do encouraging me on the
guitar
or making me hit myself in the head with
it whatever i'm happy you guys are here
but before we leave
i want to talk to you about our sponsors
because we got the best sponsors in the
business
they start with cbd lion listen
the big craze right now in this country
cbd i just went through a surgery and
cbd line was there with me
from a to z from the cream to the
roll-on
to the surgical tape i mean listen
cbd line is the best i always loved him
but after my surgery i love him more
you're asking me joey i don't know much
about cbd
that's great neither did i how did i
learn about it
you start by going to cbdlion.com read
read the third party lab results read
about the elements the treats
read what cbd might work for you whether
it's insomnia knee pain
back pain if you got a [__] problem
cbd's got an answer a cbd lion's got an
answer so go to cbdline.com right now
take a look at the great selection of
products they have from the flower
to the cream to the roll-on and pick one
and get 20
off by putting in joey joint or church
i'm gonna give you 20 off delivery right
to your [__] house from cbd lion
who takes care of you like that on a
wednesday nobody [__]
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my all-time favorites
zip [__] recruiter this goes out to
all the busy moms out there
did you know that recent data shows
that all the female-owned businesses one
and three is owned by a mom
that's right how does a mom find time to
hire
for their business while she's juggling
a family want me to tell you how
zip recruiter and right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free
free free free at ziprecruiter.com
joey again that ziprecruiter.com
joey talia goldstein is a mother of two
she also is the founder of matchmaking
company the three-day rule
her business is constantly growing and
she needs to hire new matchmakers every
month
that's a tough role to fill so who does
she call
zip recruiter the matchmaker for
matchmakers
that powerful matching technology will
help find the right people with the
right experience
and and actively invites them to apply
for your job
she's not the only one four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day where you're gonna get that type of
action at
zip recruiter so what italia did she
went and got zip recruited
the same thing i'm telling you to do if
you have a small business
a large business i don't care whether
you have three employees or three
thousand employees
zip recruiters for you so right now you
can try zip recruiter for free joey what
are you talking about nothing is free
free at ziprecruiter.com
joey again that ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free just by going to
ziprecruiter.com
recruiter is the smartest way to hire i
want to thank
the zip recruiter i want to thank cbd
lion but i want to thank you [__]
savages for always having my back
regardless of whether we do a zoom a
loom a
whatever the [__] we're doing we're
trying here and i'm trying to put a
smile on your face i'm trying to turn
that frown
upside [__] down i love you
[__] again i want to thank zip
recruiter
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
[__] draftkings i want to thank
who wasn't on monday uh manscape
shave them nuts memorial days this
weekend
use code joey and get 20 off i want to
thank all my sponsors i want to thank
you guys
i love you guys don't forget go to
draftkings sign up
they send you an email every day that
nobody else sees with different [__]
little scams
even if you could win yourself 50 bucks
what you wouldn't take 50 bucks go [__]
yourself
i love you guys have a great weekend i
love zip recruiter i love cbd line i
love you [__]
here we go see you monday [__]
happy memorial day weekend be safe
[Music]
so
you